good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video on Friday I thought you
did a great job explaining Facebook's
IPO and why stock markets are so
important but then at the end of the
video you said this a company that gives
me a free service that I use and have
never and will never pay for is somehow
worth 100 billion dollars what
now Hank I don't know if you intended
that as a rhetorical question but today
I am going to answer your okay and
here's the thing broadly speaking there
are two kinds of companies in this world
there are companies that sell you things
and then there are companies that sell
you actually come to think of it there's
a third kind of company the kind that
sells both things and you like cable
companies for instance cable companies
are like hey if you give us 80 bucks a
month we'll give you the privilege of
watching content funded primarily by
advertising but anyway Hank I believe
that the Internet Maxim is true if
you're not paying for a service you are
the product for sale Facebook is worth a
hundred billion dollars because well
actually it's not worth a hundred
billion dollars but it's worth whatever
it's worth because of you I mean
Facebook could myspace tomorrow and it
would be worth nothing that means that
companies like Facebook or Google or
Twitter or tumblr have to listen to
their users which is a good thing but
make no mistake the reason Facebook is
valuable is because you use Facebook and
you are valuable
I mean you in particular like but also
other people the stuff that you upload
to Facebook whether it's wall posts or
photographs or videos is valuable
because it brings other people in to the
site to look at that stuff and then they
in turn upload their stuff which brings
yet more people in to the site and
everything that you upload helps
Facebook know more about you which in
turn allows Facebook to know what you
are tempted to buy and encourage you to
buy it
now Hank I know that you like everyone
on the planet will insist that you don't
even look at ads anyone says that you
aren't even conscious of what's getting
hawked over there or possibly over there
damn you spatial intelligence and you'll
inevitably believe that you get the
better into the bargain because of
course you get the thing you want for
free and the ad has no effect on you
well let me just point out that a that
is exactly what advertisers want you to
think and B corporations actually have a
really good idea of how advertisements
affect your behavior in fact there are
many thousands of people who are working
full-time to make sure that the ads you
see are worth more than they cost but it
succinctly almost by definition
advertisers buy you for less than you're
worth
I mean Hank corporations spent four
hundred ninety eight billion dollars on
advertising last year
you may think that that advertising
doesn't affect your behavior but there
is half a trillion dollars that says
otherwise you and I and anyone who uses
Facebook or Twitter or Google or Angry
Birds has agreed to be commodified I'm
not saying that's a bad decision but it
is a decision and it's one that should
be made thoughtfully and consciously
Hank we've never been totally
comfortable with ads but it's always
felt like the best solution to allow us
to make the stuff that we like with
people we like but I don't know
nerdfighters I'm interested in hearing
your thoughts on this should Chrysler
and super PACs and scammy online dating
sites fund nerdfighteria and should we
be okay with being the product I look
forward to continuing that conversation
in Commons Hank thanks for teaching me
what an IPO is dftba i will see you on
friday